welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man
and today Disney finally dropped the
Black Widow trailer that feels like a
big score yes rather than a huge score
no I'm sorry that the puns they can't
all be good so throughout this video
we're gonna be raking down everything
that you need to know about the first
look the Easter eggs things you missed
and some of the best fan theories from
the internet for things that could be
happening in the movie if we're right
there's gonna be heavy spoilers here and
we will be discussing some plot leaks so
if you don't want anything about the
movie potentially ruined then I highly
suggest that you turn off now will be
shown behind the scene images as well so
yeah there may be some things that you
don't want to know in the video
hey this is heavy spoilers you know what
to expect it's your boy without the way
I just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of everything that you
need to know about the black widow
trailer okay so the teaser actually
contains a lot of footage from the Comic
Con trailer that was shown earlier in
the air at SDCC it opens with our hero
and kind of recounts all of her
appearances of the last 23 MCU movies
isn't a bird isn't a plane is it a tree
no it's Scarlett Johansson and she's
back in case you don't know a black
widow is taking place for the most part
right after the events of civil war
Widow has just broken the sokovia
accords by helping Captain America and
that she's on the run a say for the most
part because there were some recently
behind-the-scenes photos leaked that
showed a much older general Ross
therefore it's safe to assume that this
scene at least takes place after the
events of Avengers endgame as hurt is a
lot younger looking in civil war which
this film follows right after we do see
Ross looking massively de-aged in the
trailer so it is possible that this shot
was also for this moment but yeah I
don't know something about it just seems
a bit weird and the two don't really
line up now this could either show that
Widow is alive or that Ross is building
a new task force with one of the
characters in this trailer most namely
the group Thunderbolts with Yelena below
who yet we see quite a lot in this
teaser I have seen some people say that
here is just a lot older now but yeah he
doesn't look like that in 2019 so he's
clearly been aged up for the
behind-the-scenes photos and age down
for the trailer now the trailer itself
opens with an establishing shot of
Budapest and then a montage with a lot
of appearances of black widow in the MCU
this covers most of her catalogue and
it's crazy looking back at just how much
the character has actually been in
Johansson and speaks over the top of the
clips and says I used to have nothing
then I got this job this family I was
better because of it I've made a mistake
I can't go back
Widow is clearly on the run after the
events of Civil War and Ross and his
crew are hot on a tail we then also get
a bigger look at Budapest which is of
course a massive location and black
widow mythology as it's been named
dropped in every single film that the
character has appeared in however this
is the second time she's been there as
the first time that she visited the
country was before the events of the
Avengers though there could be
flashbacks laced throughout finally we
get a clip of what's gonna happen in
this new mission as widow walks into an
old run-down apartment with her gun
drawn
she cautiously takes the corners and
then hears a voice say I know you're out
there
- which she replies I know you know so
do you want to talk like grown-ups this
is of course the usual back and forth
banter that widow has with her allies
and after she turns a corner she sees
Yelena biloba played by Florence Pugh
who also has a gun drawn few questions
if they're really grown-ups and both
refused to lower their weapons and they
begin sparring both mirroring one
another and they manage to disarm the
other so that they end up with their
opposites guns yeah it's just a crazy
fight and I love the way that it plays
out they spar again to the same outcome
only this time getting their weapons
back and then a bigger fight between the
two begins it feels like a fight ripped
straight out of a Jason Bourne movie
with both characters using whatever they
can get their hands on to defeat the
other there's a lot of furniture smashed
I think Yelena grabs a knife and comes
out widowed but she blocks it and both
end up on the kitchen floor just
fighting it out now they actually on
sisters it's just that they were raised
by the same shadowy organization
apparently known as the Red Room
is led by an agent known as foster cough
which apparently rachel weisz is playing
we also see a third agent in the trailer
with them and this is definitely widow
calling or more of her allies this turns
out to be Rachel wisest character who is
allegedly their old mentor and we know
from supplementary material that she has
been through the Red Room herself five
times personally I believe she's
actually the villain and she's just
working alongside them to keep an eye on
them and eventually will end up
betraying them for the Red Roof Widow is
seen in her white costume and then we
once more see the group that trained
etosha running other young females
through the same process I think it'll
be revealed that the Red Room our
training agents to take down the US and
in the movie Natasha will destroy these
which will in some way get her back into
the good books of the u.s. even though
we do know by infinity war she is still
an outlaw it will just get Ross off her
back as he owes her a favor
Red Guardian played by David Harbor then
pops up and he's basically a Russian
version of Captain America that lost his
way to to living the high life
he saw become an alcoholic like your
dad's best mate
you know the one and now he's really
ready to get back into the fight with
the family that have come together again
oh yeah I think that wise is secretly a
double agent and this is how taskmaster
is able to stalk them throughout the
trailer we see him fighting against the
characters at several locations and a
big bust up with red guardian who I
think he's gonna quite easily beat from
here we get a montage of widow running
through a mountain range with agents
chasing her she dives off a collapsing
structure and taskmaster follows her he
feels a lot like terminator in some ways
and is nearly unstoppable by the looks
of it there's also other versions of him
as well so I don't know if it's one
entity or if there's several people
taking the moniker of the character I
think there will just be one but you'll
have very similar soldiers to him but if
one dies and another pops up it's gonna
make him seem invincible now taskmaster
is apparently a mercenary affiliated
with Vostok off who is capable of
mimicking his opponent's fighting
patterns this makes him nearly
unstoppable and the sea provides a
massive match for them now according to
the leaks to face him Natasha and Yelena
recruit their brother Red Guardian and
this looks like it lines up with a lot
of what we get here taskmaster is
rumoured to be played by ot [ __ ] Benelli
who is also supposedly playing a
character known as Rick Mason who is an
ex flame of widow he's apparently going
to be popping up throughout the movie
giving them assistance but he's also
after them and working alongside Rachel
wisest character whether that turns out
to be true as it's a fan theory that I
have going up the leaks but it makes a
lot of sense going off what we have so
far now as per usual we do have a lot of
plot leaks on the movie and I'm just
gonna be breaking down the main ones
that we have right now so if you don't
want to know them and now it's your time
to back out as it's gonna be heavy
spoilers here and I don't want to ruin
any of the major events from the movie
okay so the plot leaks say action scenes
include Natasha and Yelena fighting in a
run-down apartment Natasha and Yelena
fleeing on a motorcycle whilst
taskmaster chases them in an armored
tank Natasha and Yelena breaking Alexi
out of a gulag and Natasha infiltrating
the red-room headquarters and fighting
Vostok off in a laboratory flashbacks
Chronicle Natasha's childhood training
escape and eventual recruitment by
shield cameos include William Hurd as
secretary Thaddeus Ross Robert Downey
jr. as Tony Stark and Jeremy Renner is
also rumored to appear as Hawkeye suits
include the standard suit a white suit
for snowy environments and a reinforced
combat suit the main part twist is that
wreck Mason is taskmaster the movie ends
with Natasha reconnecting with Steve and
Sam Wilson it also apparently sets up
Yelena as the new black widow in the MCU
she's more morally ambiguous than
Natasha which creates a new dynamic for
the film's going forward now this leak
was actually dropped in September and it
lines up massively with what we've seen
here so I do think it's true but hey it
is a leak so take it with a pinch of
salt now as for the trailer overall and
just giving my general reaction to it I
definitely think that it feels like a
nice tonal shift for the MCU that lends
up a lot more with action movies like
the Winter Soldier rather than what
you'd get from your typical MCU entry it
fits so well with the character I think
and I'm glad that we're actually getting
a proper fully fledged black widow movie
in which we can learn about her past
allies and the things that really made
her who she is this is a great watch and
know that the aging on general Ross
looks absolutely
terrible they do have a lot of time to
tidy up so I can see it working really
well when it's released there's some
things that would change from the Comic
Con footage debut however on the whole
this looks like a good step forward and
though some of the green screen is a bit
hit-and-miss they have ample time to
work on it and really get things nailed
down going forward I'm probably most
excited for this film from the MCU
lineup next year as I'm still a bit
unsure about the Eternals but this is a
really good entry and hey looking
forward to it massively hopefully this
video pointed out some things you missed
and yeah roll on 20/20 now obviously I'd
love to your thoughts on the trailer and
if you have any theories surrounding it
comment below and let me know and if you
love this video 3000 then please give it
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of the latest episode
of watchmen which would be linked at the
end we go over everything you missed
from the episode and the big twist
ending so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 2 box on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel amour and all you
have to do to be in with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the black widow trailer in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen on the 15th of December
and the cell be shipped out from the
enter baguettes the price it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes pawn this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]